und nun aus gegebenem anlass zu einem
klassischen edgar wallace schocker die
toten hirne von london
diese woche sind wir alle dem
sogenannten no deal drexhage ein stück
näher gekommen leider auch im sechsten
anlauf hat ist das britische unterhaus
nicht geschafft einen weg aus der
sackgasse zu finden noch hoffen zwar
manche auf ein zweites referendum aber
was würde das bringen manche wollen dem
break cit manchen ist es war ein split
fifty fifty eigentliche und sagt wenn er
noch mal ein wahl geben würde dann wird
es 50 50 in der andere richtung gehen
[Applaus]
man könnte auch sagen theresa may führt
mit null zu null
immerhin will das unterhaus einen
odebrecht verhindern sagen sie
gleichzeitig fordern die abgeordneten
aber neue verhandlungen wozu die
eu-geführte 10.000 mal nein gesagt hat
liebe engländer erkennt man dass diese
beiden beschlüsse schließen sich aus
wien weiß ich nicht rein er und
beinfreiheit das geht nicht
ich gebe mich klar die irland frage ist
komplex aber der sogenannte back stopped
war doch mails vorschlag man fragt sich
was machen die da eigentlich in ihrem
parlament die ganze zeit hier alle
highlights vom dienstag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und
oder unterbot oder unter
alter sehen wir in der brennpunktschule
das erwarten sind so geht debattenkultur
nicht über uns in diesem baldrian
bundestag
leider haben die engländer aber selber
gar keine idee wie das eigentlich
funktionieren soll also nicht in der
zollunion bleiben aber keine
grenzkontrollen zwischen irland und
nordirland kein schimmer
das darf sich jetzt schon wieder die
arme eu überlegen du hast grenzt doch an
braig duelle belästigung ernsthaft jetzt
ist er 18 uhr auf die machen in einer
tour ihre probleme zu unsern die
deutschen und die eu wollen dass wir
etwas unterschreiben das dazu führen
könnte dass nordirland vom rest des
vereinigten königreichs getrennt wird
ich frage mich auch deutsche politiker
es akzeptieren würden wenn ein teil
deutschlands anders verwaltet würde ja
ich weiß heute haben bayern sachsen
etwas aus
[Applaus]
heute ein publikum voller separatisten
verstehen
gleichzeitig ziehen immer mehr firmen
ihr kapital aus großbritannien ab in der
trans sprache sind die engländer auf dem
besten weg zum entschuldigung drecksloch
land ja sorry
nach neuesten zahlen ist die britische
autoindustrie zum beispiel im letzten
jahr total eingebrochen um meine
lieblings meldung aus dieser woche
mcdonald's die firma mcdonald's hat
mitgeteilt bei einem notar exit wäre die
qualität ihrer produkte in gefahr
und das ist noch nicht alles wie agra so
weit das auge reicht diese britische
internet apotheke rüstet sich für den
ernstfall
viele im land beginnen das hamstern aus
angst vor dem harten drexhage es macht
sinn eine fabrik sind ohne viagra
schwierig ich glaube dafür nehmen sie
uns den grimme preis wieder weg so und
dabei hätte frau mehr regierung so viele
andere baustellen so viele echte
probleme laut einem uno-bericht leben
millionen britischer kinder in armut und
die gruppe der englischen working poor
wird auch immer größer in deutschland
undenkbar ich höre gerade meine damen
und herren es gibt wohl breaking news zu
endlosen drechsel krise
ok und zwar tut sich was auf der
französischen seite des eurotunnels für
uns vor ort in calais ist die kollegin
birte schneider
frau schneider umfasst gerade was
passiert denn da gerade das kann ich
ihnen sagen
die eu hat hier endlich den verdammten
eurotunnel zu ende aus feierabend bietet
die mauer die mauer zu wir schaffen
jetzt fakten weil die nicht zu potte
kommen auf ihrer verregneten misst
inseln
wie in dem gedicht ein korb voller rosen
ein zärtlicher kuss liegt uns am arsch
wir machen jetzt schluss ja ist leider
noch nicht ganz fertig da kommen immer
noch britische flüchtlinge sie ganz
schwer zu integrieren
gleichzeitig wollen vereinzelter
afrikaner trotz allem nach england zu
gehen dann nicht hinweise scheiße das
ist mir jetzt frau kollegin doch ein
bisschen zu viel besser ich kann das
nicht mehr hören
schon beim wort brekzie krieg ich pickel
drechselt es klingt die katzenfutter von
lidl über ein jahr verhandlungen jetzt
wollen wir mit uns nochmal über irland
reden wir wollen aber nicht mit euch
über irland reden
never etwa acht mal oma backen gemacht
auch die beagle
[Applaus]
drei warme mahlzeiten park sind halt was
feines hat üben horten die ersten jahr
schon die ersten lebensmittel wenn ihr
hunger habt könnt ihr euch achter hate
überbacken
naja gut wird irgendein deal wäre schon
wichtig für beide seien wählte es reicht
jetzt wir können keine zur junioren aber
schon über eine zollunion man engländer
man kann auch in der eu sein und
trotzdem ein egoistisches arschloch so
wie wir gegen kein eu land laufen so
viele vertragsverletzungsverfahren wie
geht unsere verguckte energiewende haben
wir vorher mit keinem europäischen land
abgestimmt wenn es passt scheißen wir
auf eu regeln
das ist die deutsche lösung sich zur ehe
bekennen aber flatrate im swinger-club
davon könnte eine scheibe abschneiden
der jugend katar pins fromm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
genau
jemand es wichtig schon klar
man kann so viel von uns lernen vor
schneider aus meiner oder man verschiebt
den ganzen dreck sind doch noch mal
quatsch morgen machen wir hier dicht und
die was habt ihr gesagt wird dass
schneider war damen und herren guten tag
wie könnte ich sie für ein abo des heute
show you tube kanal als begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort